some viewers didn't love how you and
Natalie interacted with Tom yeah why do
you have to say the people who maybe
would call you guys Mean Girls in that
house I would say that they they weren't
in the house and they didn't see the
whole picture and we knew that Tom would
be edited in a good light but I think if
they were actually in the house cuz
there was a point in the house I mean
it's no shocker that Tom had a clean
boat to get him out of the house so they
looked like we were bullies then the
whole house wanted him out at a point
because the energy was so crazy in the
house so I would just say look at the
other votes and we like oh well why
didn't they want someone else to go so
look at that and that stands for itself
right you got to reunite with all your
cast mates your house mates tonight did
you and Natalie get to exchange any
words and kind of settle what was
unsettled when you both walked out you
know just I'm just being super positive
with everybody I'm super happy to see
everyone you know I I think this is
great you know like I said you know it's
just a game you in have the best
relationship with in the house what's
the conversation gonna be tonight
um I think everything is just gonna be
all positive and love because at the end
of the day we were in there we were
competing we had alliances so if you
weren't a part of certain people's
alliances you're their opponent you know
it's all in good fun there's only one
winner and all in all I think we're all
really happy about it so hopefully
there's no hard feelings whatsoever and
I'm just excited to see everybody
because it was amazing
[Music]